sukuna might have a twin brother who
fought alongside him during the hyan
period and who was eventually absorbed
into Suk kuna's main body the real life
sukuna that the jjk character was based
on was described as having two faces
four arms and four legs it is almost as
if sukuna was two people fused together
which is what made him so much stronger
than a normal person but it's possible
that the historical sukuna was actually
two separate individuals perhaps two
twin brothers who looked alike and who
fought together as one one they fought
together so effectively that to their
opponents it seemed like they were
fighting a single monstrous enemy with
four legs four arms and two faces one on
the front of his head and one on the
back but if sukunai jjk has a brother
then where is he now and could he have
been reincarnated inside of Yuji to find
out click on my full video at the bottom
of your screen right now